thank you it's my real pleasure to
introduce you tonight Jack Steinberg who
is the national national education
correspondent at the new york times i
was tempted to start my introduction by
saying my friend and Westlands friend
Jack Steinberg but I want to be quick to
add to that that throughout the entire
process for this project which as I
think many of you know started with a
series of articles to run in the new
york times in this spring of two
thousand and as we began this journey
together it was always very clear to me
how important it was to Jacques that he
maintained his journalistic integrity in
fact I think more than once he said to
me I'm a reporter I can write whatever I
want I'm just to illustrate that point
but what we wanted the collective hope
from the very beginning of this project
was to create a story and to tell that
story from the inside out we thought and
I think we still think that is the story
that hadn't been told before and as this
has one on well beyond that the New York
Times articles and become this book the
gatekeepers we have felt that we could
pull the lid off the box open the doors
to a process that that many people had
not understood well and we feel at this
point that that's exactly what we've
done and that's why I jock is here
tonight to share with you his view and
his perspective on this very successful
book and very successful joint venture I
had the privilege of seeing Jacques in
action about the book earlier this fall
he was speaking at the national
association of college admissions
counseling I was standing in the back of
the room with my good friend and
colleague bill Fitzsimmons who is the
Dean of admission at Harvard and this
was about a week or so after there'd
been a similar presentation at the
Harvard School of Education and Bill
Fitzsimmons had had the pleasure of
introducing Jacques and bill being bill
he'd read the book before he made that
introduction and what he shared with me
as we were listening
to Jack and and other colleagues talk
about the motivations behind this book
was highly complementary he tilt
Fitzsimmons felt that we had done a
great service together in helping
parents and families and counselors and
other educators understand how the
admissions process really works but
there was another compliment and I'm not
sure it's one that that Jack has heard
yet and and that was that we have before
us a wonderful example of a reporter who
has tried very hard to get it right and
who comes across in every interaction is
being completely trustworthy in that
process I concur completely after having
been through this with Jack but also
felt that was high praise and very well
deserved I want to end my introduction
by telling you a more recent story two
nights ago I was in Guatemala City
talking to students and parents there
about us higher education and the
process that they were embarking upon
and more confused perhaps than than
those of you here tonight and we talked
through the process I answer questions
and at the end I offered if there was
anyone with a personal question to
please come up front and I'd be happy to
talk with them the first family that
appeared and miraculously immediately
right in front of me turn to them said
how can I help you and the dad with this
great big grin on his face who's
professor at University in Guatemala PhD
from Duke Sun rising through the high
school years in the process he just said
I just want to meet you because I've
been reading about you every night and
and I'm glad my husband wasn't standing
there next to me or something like that
I dunno but but he said I am deeply
engrossed in the gatekeepers and I
wanted to come up and shake your hand
and thank you for this because he
learned I said how'd you learn about he
said you've read about it in Newsweek
magazine and also in the Duke alumni
news encouraging this alumni to take
care to take a look at the book and I
said well what do you think and he said
it's a great read and it's extremely
helpful and I want to thank you so with
that I would like to thank you and
introduce to you my good friend Jack
Steinberg
Thank You Nancy if I have talked about
this book and your University in nearly
two dozen cities around the country over
the last four weeks or so and I think my
wife Sharon who's here can tell you that
this was the one that I was most excited
about and looking forward to it it's a
strange thing for a Dartmouth alumnus to
feel a sense of homecoming at Wesleyan
but but that is really how I'm feeling
tonight I I'm extremely grateful to to
Wesleyan for its courage and and trust
in me in allowing me to tell this story
which really had never been told no
university had opened up its admissions
process to an outsider with so few
strings for such an extended period of
time and I know I don't need to tell you
that that is just very much in the
Wesleyan tradition it is the Wesleyan
way there are so many people that I want
to thank here but I'll have to settle
they will all have to settle for three
tonight I do want to thank Barbara Jane
Wilson who was the first person at
Wesleyan who I talked to about this
project and Doug Bennett the president
who gave us the green light and then
Nancy muslin who had the experience of
arriving at Wesleyan from Cornell on
December first of 1999 to find a new
york times reporter sitting at her
committee table for her first day of
work I cannot imagine what that must
have been like and the fact that she is
here tonight with us is is amazing
frankly she has a stronger Constitution
than I do this I came away from spending
eight months more or less as an observer
in this office with one main insight
it's it's not a very sophisticated
insight but I think it's important and I
think it's one that often gets missed
that this is an incredibly human process
it may not always be humane given the
large number of applicants and the small
number of slots but it is very human and
it is carried out by human beings people
who do this sort of admissions work not
because they enjoy saying no so much
more than they get an opportunity say
yes but really because they care about
the issue of acts
to higher education and want to give
every applicant and truly every
applicant at a chance to make the best
possible case for admission I don't want
to read too much to you tonight but
there is one excerpt that I think is
sort of appropriate in terms of of
showing how close the book gets to the
ground and and how close the people who
do this work get to the process of the
book follows a year in the life of the
Wesleyan admissions office this excerpt
is set at the point the process when the
waiting list is being assembled at this
point 1800 offers of admission have been
extended for the class of 2004 if
westland gets its math right about 700
of those students are going to accept
Wesleyan if the math is off by a lot and
they don't get as many they will go to
the waiting list at this point in the
process another fifteen hundred
applicants have been invited or nearly
1500 have been invited to join the
waiting list of those 1500 about 700
will say to Wesleyan we'd like to be
considered on the waiting list the year
that I was there of those 700 about 10
to 15 would be pulled off the waiting
list admissions officers have lots of
terms of art the only one you need to
know to understand this example is the
word work card the work hard is the
valid the admissions officers fill out
when they read a file with the odds
against acceptance now staggeringly high
some applicants always took the
directive of demonstrating their ardor
to the extreme in 1993 for example the
Wesleyan admissions committee had placed
Carter L bays an aspiring playwright
from Shaker Heights Ohio on the waiting
list Carter not surprisingly was
convinced that the committee had made a
terrible mistake and not accepting him
immediately and so he wrote to the
committee to prove that I am worthy of
attending your school and that you are
worthy of having me as a student I'm
going to send you a postcard every day
until you accept me
the first day a postcard arrived that
was titled reason number one why Carter
L bay's belongs at Wesleyan University
that reason Carter row was that he had
recently won a local playwriting
festival the next day reason number two
promised that Carter would take full
advantage of the millions of volumes in
olin library before long Judy good Dale
the office manager and Charlotte Lazar
the offices longtime Systems Manager
were racing each other to the mailbox to
retrieve Carter's latest note each
wanted to be the first to read aloud
that Carter was an excellent singer or
that Carter could chew gum and ride a
bike at the same time they then
decorated their bulletin boards with the
photographs on the opposite side of the
card as if the cards had been sent by a
Daffy uncle on vacation there was one
with a collection of dogs playing poker
another with a svelte Elvis and a third
that displayed a replica of Stonehenge
made out of toothpicks without fail a
card arrived every day for nearly a
month when the deans asked Judy to send
up the work cards those ballots of those
applicants whom they would consider
accepting off the waiting list that year
she and Charlotte decided to cast a rare
vote they put Carter's card on the very
top he was our personal case Charlotte
recalled when an admissions officer
telephone Carter a few days later to
notify him that he had indeed been
accepted she added that she was calling
over the objection of the assistants in
the office who had begged her to delay
the call they wanted more mail that day
Carter dashed off a final post card
containing only a two-word message thank
you but the relationship didn't end
there once enrolled at Wesleyan Carter
became a regular contributor to the
student newspaper The Argus and Judy and
Charlotte clipped the articles like
proud parents though they were eager to
meet him they could never summon the
courage to invite him for a visit to the
office but they never forgot him after
Carter graduated they logged on to the
alumni database to learn of his first
job out of college and were hardly
surprised at what flashed on the
computer screen staff writer The Late
Show with David Letterman applying to
Wesleyan as it turned out had prepared
Carter elbows well for his chief
responsibility on the Letterman Show it
was Carter who wrote the on-air
responses to Dave's viewer mail it was
almost poetic Charlotte said
now I tell the story as I have a lot of
different places around the country the
last few weeks not with the hope that
the west lane admissions office or other
admissions offices are going to get
bombarded by postcards from kids in fact
I tell audiences and I should reassure
Barbara Jan and Nancy that probably a
999 out of a thousand cases this would
have backfired and the kid would have
obviously come off as arrogant or
annoying and yet in this case Carter was
able by being so sincere and by being
himself to really convey who he was and
not only did this process allow for
admissions officers to discover who
Carter was but the assistance in the
office the people who often opened that
mail were the ones who were sort of
captivated by him and we're literally
able to carry his application over the
goal line I also tell students I should
reassure you and parents that if Carter
were not able to do the work at Wesleyan
if it was not believed that he could
have done the work that all of these
wonderful postcards probably would have
gone for naught but the fact was that
like so many applicants to westland it
was believed that he could do the work
and he had managed to get across how
badly he wanted to come here I think
that that example underscores that this
is a process that is messy and I mean
that in a very complementary way it's
idiosyncratic it's sometimes arbitrary
it can be contradictory and it's
extremely personal to the people who do
this work but I would argue having spent
so much time here that it is hardly
formulaic and and that all of these how
to get in books that proclaim or you
know at least pretend to tell you that
there is this formula that if only you
figure it out and get into schools like
Westland or Williams or Amherst I just
couldn't find that formula and I think I
was here long enough that I would have
seen it if it existed I've had a lot of
parents tell me on the road that it's
unnerving that there's no formula they
really would love to be able to know
that there was a way they could control
this process I actually find it
reassuring the fact there is no formula
that we can't control it as applicants
or as parents means that we can spend
our time doing the things that are
important and not trying to gain this
process I want to tell you a little bit
about how I picked Wesleyan for this
project this
I am a national education correspondent
at the New York Times and one of the
first things I did in my capacity of
that job three years ago was to attend a
convention of 3,500 admissions officers
and guidance counselors can you imagine
that party it actually was a lot of fun
and and I learned a tremendous amount
and build his the long time the end of
admissions at Bates button hold me and
said that he had made an offer
repeatedly to various reporters to come
spend a year in his admissions office in
Bates in Lewiston Maine and wouldn't
want to spend that time and it sounded
like a terrific offer particularly as
somebody like I was who always wondered
how I had gotten into Dartmouth which
had been my dream college I'd always
wanted to see this process up close the
problem with Bates for the sake of this
example was that while they were highly
selective and turning away far more kids
than they accepted they did not require
the s80 and I felt that if this series
were to be done right it would have to
be representative of as many of the
highly selective zaz possible in part
because so many of the readers in our
audience had their sights trained on
these schools and and so we turned Bates
down and then I set about trying to find
a school that was more representative of
this process I have to say quite frankly
that there were very few schools that
were interested in casting light on this
process what could possibly be gained by
showing the sort of calculations that
were made when the issues involved were
race and ethnicity and athletic ability
alumni connections money it's not
something that many institutions thought
they could benefit from having exposed
to the brighter light happily and as
build a wesleyan was not one of those
schools that had that sort of
squeamishness my request came at the
very moment that Barbara Jane had been
talking about how this process could be
made more open and the timing was
terrific the book spends a lot of time
following one admissions officer in
particular Ralph Figueroa Ralph at the
time we met him had been an admissions
officer at Wesleyan for five years for
the four years prior to that he had been
an admissions officer at Occidental and
prior to that he was a lawyer and it
turned out that Rao
background was as representative of
anybody else on that 10 member committee
which is to say there really is no
template for the people who do this work
they bring an enormous amount of
diversity of life experience this
process that's intentional the hope that
is a committee that is diverse in the
broadest sense of the word diversity
will yield a class that is equally
diverse among ralphs colleagues was
Nancy who has a degree in science from
Cornell is that correct but also had
Nancy had also been a management trainee
at Sears Nancy's colleague Greg pike had
been a resident administrator in a
psychiatric halfway house he'd also been
a food-stamp interviewer near a Boeing
plant in Washington Chris Lancer in the
office has a degree in English but also
had been a California State humane
officer which at times boiled down to
being a dog catcher Chris's specialty
truly was breaking up fights between pit
bulls and I have to say that sometimes
that came in handy in the Westland
admissions office there was one
individual in the office who his
colleagues are sort of three-quarters
convinced is in the witness protection
program because this individual is
secretive about the most basic details
of his life such as his address
I would like to say that I used a
scientific process to sort of zero in on
Ralph I did not and I think that's
appropriate given that there is so
little science involved in this process
that it can be so subjective why
couldn't I be subjective as well more
than anything I wanted to show
admissions officers reading files at
home I felt that there had been other
articles that showed admissions officers
in the committee round sometimes yelling
at each other hashing over candidates I
felt that much of the decisions that
were made were sort of hashed out in
solitude and indeed Nancy and Ralph and
their colleagues would read at home at
times 30 files a day 12 hours a day six
days a week for the better part of eight
weeks I felt that while on its surface
that didn't seem very dramatic it seemed
incredibly dramatic to me given that
some of the preliminary decisions were
being made at this point in the process
I had a very specific criteria for what
admissions officer I would be able to
follow I needed this person not to have
a dog or a cat because I was allergic
very allergic and you guessed it ralph
was the only one we could find or at
least who said he did not have a dog or
a cat I heard a rumor that this
individual who's purported to be the
witness protection program upon hearing
of my allergy went out and got a dog
but who would know because nobody knew
where he lived the book also follows six
applicants to westland and all of them
use their real names the details of
their files are are real I think they
are the true heroes of this book frankly
they shared incredible details of their
lives many of them embarrassing many of
them knew of course when I approached
them after the process was over that
they had not been admitted to Wesleyan
and yet they were willing to tell their
story to me and to this larger audience
because they genuinely believed it would
help applicants and parents who would
come after them I want to tell you very
briefly about just a couple of them one
young woman is named Juliana been teased
Juliana attended the harvard westlake
School in Los Angeles one of the finest
prep schools on the west coast and
probably in this country Ralph our main
character first finds Juliana on his
radar when she is in the ninth grade he
sees her in a production of West Side
Story her guidance counselor is sitting
next to ralphs and sort of elbows him
and says you're going to want to know
this kid what was so extraordinary about
Juliana in part it was that she could
not only check the box on her
application for a white applicant but
also an applicant who is black and
Hispanic her father had been raised in
the Amazon her first language was
Portuguese but it wasn't just racial and
ethnic diversity that made Juliana stand
out she would turn out to have a
near-perfect s80 score she was a dancer
she was a terrific writer she was the
social conscience of harvard-westlake
which she attended on scholarship and in
in Giuliana's case it was a foregone
conclusion I thought that she was going
to get into westland and probably
anywhere else she applied the question
for me was was she going to choose to
come here and there was a real risk with
Ralph pursuing somebody who was so
popular that ralph was the one who was
going to have his heart broken and I
don't think we're used to seeing
admissions officers I'm getting their
hearts broken and in fact it happens
more often than we know and in that case
I wanted to follow Juliana for that
reason another person who we follow in
the book is becca gin all Beka is a
classmate of Juliana's like a lot of
applicants bekomme doesn't mistake in
her high school career
one day in her sophomore year she
accepted a pot brownie before first
period class at the harvard westlake
campus she was one of two dozen kids to
accept the brownie she was the only one
to turn herself in she took her
punishment she when I'm on to become the
president of the student body and the
president of the honor board and not
surprisingly when her senior year rolled
around she decided that this was a story
that she wanted to tell in her in her
college essay I felt this was incredibly
precious cargo to transport in an essay
I wanted to watch how it would be
received I liked the idea that she was
somebody who had asked Ellen in her
closet and was willing to sort of
confront it head-on in her college
application and as you will see in the
book it got a different reaction from
some people at westland than it did from
some people at Cornell further
underscoring how human this process is
and in subject to to the desires and
interests of human beings I'll tell you
about one other applicant we follow in
the book her name is Agee Ramirez Agee
grew up in Washington Heights in New
York City her parents are Dominican
neither of them went to college through
sheer determination Aggie got herself a
scholarship to a boarding school outside
of Baltimore called oldfield's to give
you a flavor of the school which is
mostly populated by young women from
Georgia Virginia and Texas one out of
every three girls who attends the school
brings her own horse to old feels to
board along with her Aggie to say the
least did not have her own horse and yet
she was elected by these young women as
the president of the student body I was
with Ralph on the februari day where he
was reading on the porch of his home and
Aggies application he had never met
Aggie sort of came before him and he was
immediately captivated by this story the
fact that this was the young woman who
the women at these school this school
had chosen to elect as their president
and Ralph was instantly drawn to her she
wrote similarly in her essay how
grateful she would be to take a Wesleyan
education and what she would learn from
it and bring it back to Washington
Heights where she hoped to become a
leader but this is messy sort of
complicated work and Giuliana I'm sorry
Beckett
I have been talking about this too long
Aggie had some seasoned D's in the
senior year after having a pretty good
run in the first three years I'm one of
those C's was in Spanish which struck
Ralph as odd given that it was her
native language or parents native
language she also had an essay t-score
that did not break 1100 and at westland
the median s80 score of the class would
be near 1,400 so this was a complicated
case for Ralph and he spent a lot of
time looking out the window as he
considered it and I wanted to follow
Aggie through this process to look at
the larger issues of affirmative action
and to see that while everybody in the
westland admissions office subscribe to
the notion of affirmative action there
were often nuances and and the question
of whether Aggie could do the work at
Wesleyan became very paramount as the
process moved on I want to talk very
very briefly about what happens to an
application once it is received at
westland I found it very reassuring one
of the many reassuring things I found
was that in nearly every case an
application is read by at least two
admissions officers and as somebody who
went into this process as an applicant
and as an observer really wondering
whether it didn't they look at an essay
t-score and if it was below a certain
level just sort of close the folder and
put it aside I can tell you having spent
so much time here that that just wasn't
the case they really looked very very
deep into the file again to give each
applicant an opportunity to make that
best case for admission if the first two
individuals who read the file had some
sense of agreement about whether an
admissions off whether the applicant
should be admitted denied or put on the
waiting list more often than not Nancy
or Greg at least in the year that i was
there would tend to endorse that
decision as long as it fit in with
things that were happening elsewhere in
the process but if there was any
question if the two people read the file
and could not come to agreement and very
often it was the case that two people
could read the same file and come away
with very different impression the
committee of the whole was convened
because in my opinion as an observer
wesley and wanted to make sure that
every possible effort was made to give
that person a fair hearing in the year
that i was at westland
as an observer it came down to 400 such
cases in the last week of the process
with about a hundred seats in the class
remaining each of those cases was
debated for at least five minutes 80
cases a day for five days with a vote of
the majority ruling each case had been
considered by at least two people they
had compile notes on it they had been
considered thoroughly and ultimately the
entire committee was given a chance to
pass judgment what were they looking for
when they opened that file again I found
it reassuring that it seemed to me more
often than not that the rigor of the
curriculum how hard a course load had a
student selected was paramount it would
seem to me that that was considered
before it was even considered what the
grades were they really wanted to see
was this the sort of individual who
sought out challenges who tried to max
out on the curriculum at his or her
school it was only then that they looked
at what the grades were I was glad to
see that at times a be in a hard course
was more valued than an A in an easy
course although obviously the hope was
that there was an a in the hard course
in terms of extracurricular activities
it seemed to me that it was not the five
page resume of activities that so many
students compiled that didn't seem to be
what they were looking for in fact I saw
Ralph put more than a few five page
resumes very nicely back in the folder
it seemed to me that it was a couple of
activities certainly at least two that
an applicant had spent some time on
ideally three or four years if there was
some sense within the folder either in
the essay or in the comments of a
guidance counselor or a teacher that the
applicant had actually enjoyed these
activities that tended to help certainly
the committee knew that there were more
than a few kids who did things because
they thought the committee wanted them
to also if there was any evidence of
leadership within the activity that
seemed to be something that was prized
the s80 score was complicated in terms
of how it was weighed I'll talk briefly
about it now and if you have more
questions I and and hopefully some of
the folks can watch wesleyan can shed
light on it but in my experience every
essay t-score the s80 score of each
applicant was considered within the
context of that app
its entire experience educationally as
well as their life experience at home
there's certainly more than a little
evidence that one of the things that the
s80 measures is the sort of intellectual
enrichment that students get at home
after school and westland like a lot of
colleges wanted to make sure that it
took into account things like the
educational attainment of parents and it
was one of many factors that was put
into play but I'm an applicant like
myself certainly white upper-middle
class the son of a doctor the
expectation or hope I think going into
the process would have been that someone
like me would have had a 1400 an
applicant like Aggie neither of whose
parents had gone to college an applicant
of color perhaps an 1100 might have done
it given other things that might have
been present in the folder a lot of
white parents have certainly said to me
on the road these past few weeks that
doesn't not necessarily sound like the
fairest process some parents whose
children do very well on the s80 tend to
think that it should be seen in a vacuum
I'm probably not one of those people but
I often refer them to a quote from
Douglas Bennett the president of
Westland in the book in which Doug says
that fairness is not necessarily the
first objective of this process because
how could you possibly define what was
fair with all the different factors that
are at play here I've tried to tell
parents whose students don't have that
1400 not to give up hope that it was my
experience that the admissions officer
what as at Wesleyan tended to dig very
very deep to figure what else there was
in that file that would merit admission
we tend to think of admissions officers
as talent scouts and they certainly are
that but I also saw them as social
engineers they're building a community
and in that community you need students
with high s80 scores you need students
who've done original scientific research
people who can help the professor's here
in those science departments do that
work but you also need people of various
talents not only athletics I've told the
story reluctantly on the road but I'll
tell it here that the Ivy League I'm
told has a perennial shortage
of tuba players at times they surely
will not have shortage of tuba players
when I'm done talking this year there
was fairly be a surplus but the fact is
that you can't have a marching band
without a tuba player you can't have an
orchestra without a bassoonist or an
oboe player and these sorts of things
can sometimes be as valuable as a high
ass a t-score as long as there is indeed
evidence in the file that this is
somebody who could do the work at a
place like Westland and who would add to
the community as a writer I was
reassured to see that many admissions
officers gave the essay a lot of
attention I don't think ralph was unique
in this capacity but it Ralph became so
engrossed in the essays that he would
often read his favorite essays aloud
with his wife in the evening after he
had closed down for the night and often
they would cry together over the beauty
in these essays that as somebody who
spent a lot of time on his essay that
made me quite happy I it didn't wasn't
always the case that the essay would
sway the case one way or the other in
fact it very often did not but it
sometimes did and it seemed to me that
the saddest experiences were the kids
who were so obviously trying to
second-guess this process who thought
they knew what the admissions committee
wanted to see in an essay and had tried
to give the committee what the committee
wanted and and in fact could have had
possibly no idea and and probably would
have been a better off not
second-guessing themselves the best
example of this to me came last fall
after I've been at Wesleyan when Ralph
told me that very few applicants for
early decision last November had written
about September 11th even though it was
only two months earlier in fact Ralph
did not read a single September 11th
essay ordinarily Ralph would probably
told kids that the essay is a terrific
opportunity to sort of show what makes
them different what about their take on
the world is different what makes them
tick how can they sort of distinguish
themselves from others and yet this was
one of those myriad exceptions to all
that conventional wisdom that are in
those how to get in books Ralph felt
that September 11th was such an
extraordinary event in these kids young
five times that he really wanted to hear
what they had to say and wouldn't have
been especially bothered if all of them
had weighed in on it Ralph thought that
by not commenting on September 11th they
came off as shallow and of course none
of them wrote about it all of them came
off as shallow which meant none of them
were hurt in the process but the fact
was that it made Ralph sad knowing that
so many college counselors had probably
advised these kids not to write about
September 11th and had wound up sort of
kicking themselves by second-guessing
this process in the end I think that I
was reassured on so many counts to see
how this process was practiced here and
to do enough reporting to other places
to know that Wesleyan is hardly unique
in the sort of human touch that is
brought to this process and i think that
the only thing I could possibly advise
applicants given the long odds against
acceptance and the complicated nature of
the sort of evaluation of this work is
that maybe you really can sort of be
yourself take the hardest courses engage
in activities that interest you write an
essay that really conveys who you are
and how you think and really sort of let
the chips fall where they may I don't
think there's much more than that that I
could advise applicants and I think that
that is probably good news thank you
very much
if you have questions I'm happy to
entertain them yes you answered it
actually your last remark I was going to
say to what extent would Wesley ins
admissions process and department be
typical or atypical did you have a
chance really the sort of see or get a
feeling for how that might be sure I
talked to a lot of Dean's admissions and
admissions officers at a lot of other
places everybody's process is a little
different at Harvard for example all of
the decisions are made in the committee
of the whole Harvard feels that these
decisions are too important to be left
to just a couple of people at Dartmouth
almost none of the decisions are made in
the committee of the whole the feeling
at Dartmouth is that admissions
committees can develop into cliques at
times and certainly that happened at
times at westland and that sometimes the
decision can have more to do with the
dynamics between the admissions officers
then the applicant was actually on the
table wesleyan sort of was in the middle
on that places like Caltech certainly
use professors more the specialized
schools I'm at Cornell professors are
more involved in the process than at
westland although professors are
certainly consulted at westland as well
but I think the most telling thing about
this process and how similar it is is
that Nancy arrived from Cornell in
December and was reading applications
within days clearly those systems were
similar enough that she was able to get
working right away I liken it to being
traded from one basketball team to
another in this case you know probably
from the the the Nets to the Celtics but
it it the plays were different but the
game was the same I'm call furstenberg
the dean of admissions at Dartmouth was
formerly the Dean here I think these
schools with fine line differences are
pretty much the same and i think that at
least in talking about four dozen or so
highly selective private colleges the
Wesleyan approach is not all that unique
it's certainly not similar to what
happens a lot of the big state
universities where there's so many
applications and so little manpower that
some of this material really does have
to be fed into a computer
at Michigan there's 150 point formula in
which grade point average and class rank
and extracurriculars and a few points
for race help yield the class no and
there really are 20 points for race on
that scale at Michigan but Wesleyan is
representative I'm confident of that yes
it's currently of girls they're getting
girls to excel and boys are falling
behind it was was just within the last
couple weeks I did I forget I did not
see the piece but I've certainly heard
about it the the only thing that sort of
struck me was that during the early
decision process when they had come
through the early decision process and
we're heading into the main round the
ratio of girls to boys was higher and
and I'm not quite sure why that was but
by the end of the class it was pretty
well equalized maybe the girls were more
highly motivated to apply early i'm not
sure but I'm not somebody who tends to
put a lot of stock into these you know
comparisons between genders when it
comes to various abilities maybe I say
that at my peril but yes and could you
describe a little bit the process you
went through in arriving at Wesleyan
sure once Bates said no I had like an
applicant I really got excited by the
idea and and I wanted to do this at a
highly selective private I wanted it to
be within a two-hour drive of New York
City because I needed to cover other
stories for the New York Times so that
you could almost draw a circle on a map
and then I just started talking to
people and there were some admissions
offices who turned us down there were
others that actually said yes and I was
advised by several guidance counselor's
in the know that the deans that some of
those schools might show one thing while
I was there and do quite another while I
wasn't but but everybody all of those
guidance counselors
were unanimous in the sentiment that it
wesleyan what I saw would be the real
thing and that there would be no sort of
sanitizing of the process but again I
was no more scientific about this
process that an applicant is in trying
to figure out that list of schools that
you sort of focus on and and I think
that in a weird way you know applicants
should be reassured that it I almost in
effect threw a dart at a board and and
came up with the terrific educational
experience and and they probably can too
yes I've been talking to lots of
guidance counselors and some of them are
here tonight some of them are repeat
observers I'm amazed to say groupies but
that I gotta win yet but the guidance
counselors are convinced that they are
the sequel and more than a few have
asked me to follow them around for a
year several parents at harvard-westlake
told me that they were the real story
and that I should follow them around but
I I have a feeling that the next project
won't have anything to do with education
but it's been fun yes Nancy given you
know where you are tonight and where
you've been could you share with us some
of your observations from your travels
and sort of give us the inside story of
what's happened since the book hit the
stands and and you know sort of how your
life has changed and what you've learned
over this last month sure I mean I'll
talk less personally and then more
personally I mean the I've seen a lot of
parents on the road I'm in places like
Seattle and LA and Albuquerque upwards
of 300 parents in an evening and I know
you know how anxious they are I didn't
quite realize the depth of that anxiety
it is the the desire in this country to
align oneself with a marquee institution
is more powerful certainly than when I
went to apply to college in the
mid-1980s and there's a lot of
irrationality at an appearance last
night a young woman asked if I thought
it would be possible for her
to apply to three colleges binding early
decision in in the way the rules work on
these schools are pretty clear as you
know Wesleyan has a binding an early
admission program you only can apply to
one and you have to assure the
institution that you're applying to that
you're only applying to one because if
you get in and the decision is binding
you have to go and and she knew this and
yet thought that what harm could come
from applying to three binding programs
when the odds were so great that she'd
probably only be accepted to one I feel
very unclean ax but on this one I felt
like I was on pretty firm ground and
telling her that the rules were pretty
clear two questions later her father
stood up and said what would be the
penalty for my daughter if she applied
to those three schools early decision
and I told him that as you know these
institutions share lists of who they've
accepted early and that if Yale accepted
her and informed Dartmouth and brown of
this and Dartmouth and brown came back
and said oh we've heard from her too in
fact we accepted her she would probably
not be admitted anywhere and that he
would be hurting his daughter and he was
very open about the fact that this was
his idea not his daughter's idea I've
met parent one parent in Philadelphia
asked me one parent in Philadelphia said
that she was concerned that in her
daughter's personal statement her
daughter had used the pronoun I too much
and she wondered how many times was too
many times because she was afraid that
her daughter was going to come off as
conceited again this was one of these
ones where i felt like i could give
advice as a writer I said that it was
difficult to write a personal statement
in the third person and and that and
that she had probably not exceeded
Westlands quota for the pronoun I I've
asked ed parents I've had parents asked
me to inscribe their book to their child
good luck getting into Stanford I of
course have written good luck getting
into Wesley but it it's it's it's sad
and and I know that I was caught up and
in his applicant I'll try not to get
caught up in it as a parent but it's
it's fed by so many things and
and there's I don't know quite what to
do to sort of tamp it down but my
contribution was to shed light on this
process at least now they don't need to
be anxious about knowing what's going to
happen when the file lands at a place
like Wesley and they can imagine exactly
what's going to happen to that file and
that must be reassuring on the other
hand knowing what's going to happen to
that file has has created other
anxieties for particularly for kids who
sort of see themselves in this process
and wonder how they will cut through it
it's a us about what it's been like for
me it's a this is completely alien that
territory to be to be answering the
questions and not asking them and I look
very I look forward and I know you're
smiling that the tables have been turned
but I look forward to returning to
asking questions and writing about the
answers although this has been fun and
it's fun to talk about I wrote this book
because I always wondered how i got into
Dartmouth genuinely wondered my essay
t-score I suspected at the time i
applied was below the median at
Dartmouth that year I've since found out
that I was right I applied from a little
tiny rural high school in southeastern
Massachusetts that had not sent someone
to Dartmouth for ten years prior and
that person had been a quarterback I'm
sure I'm not telling any great secret
and saying I was no quarterback I was a
journalist and and I always sort of
wondered what it was about me that
Dartmouth saw fit to take that year and
and while I'll never know for sure I
certainly have a better sense I think
having sat in on the process here yes do
the admissions people see the the
applicants much like themselves when
they were younger or do they see a very
different people coming out of the
schools today I mean do they see things
shaping their world very differently or
did they see a lot of commonalities when
I was a kid was just like this I think
it's hard to generalize I mean certainly
when some of these admissions officers
despite being as young as they are we're
applying there was not this level of
competition certainly in terms of this
process but to take your question a
little different way
I was amazed and and surprised at times
at how excited somebody like Ralph or
Nancy might get when they saw an
applicant who looked a lot like
themselves in the pile there are
certainly applicants like Nancy who
antsy grew up in upstate New York was
the number one at her rural high school
worked 20 hours a week and a job took
courses at a local community college is
that am I going too far or and and I
think when when Nancy would see an
applicant like that she would often get
very excited I mean who wouldn't to see
themselves sort of staring back at them
from the pool on the other hand Nancy
could be very tough on applicants of a
similar profile who hadn't quite done
that and when she knew that it was
possible to do so there's a gentleman in
the admissions office who was an orphan
by the age of 13 and a number of
applicants will write about loss very
profound loss the loss of a parent
during the freshman or sophomore year of
high school which obviously had a big
effect on grades on these cases often
got to the committee because they were
complicated you would think that this
individual who was often the first to
tear up when he heard one of these
stories would be a real softy when it
came to these kids and yet he was often
in my experience one of the toughest
people on these kids because if someone
just wrote about the loss for the sake
of getting kind of an Oprah moment for
lack of a better word from the committee
that was one thing this individual
wanted to see kids who explained how
they had moved on somehow and and
learned and grown from these experiences
so it could work both ways Ralph is very
very serious of about affirmative action
as you see in the book he's
mexican-american one of his
responsibilities at Wesleyan was to keep
an eye out for Hispanic kids but Ralph
is also as the people who know him know
really riotously funny and and has lots
of interests that a lot of us do not
share and and
one applicant who I was sitting with
Ralph when he was reading the file and
the applicant mentioned in his essay
just almost as an aside that something
about wearing an x-men t-shirt and it's
one of these moments where Ralph sort of
looked up and smiled and I interrupted
Ralph as I did so often and asked him
what it was and he said it was this
reference the kid made a reference to
x-men Ralph as it turned out at Stanford
had a roommate who had probably every
x-men comic book in fact this individual
had written his senior thesis about
x-men and and Ralph had read every comic
book along with his roommate this
applicants fade at wesleyan did not
hinge on whether or not he had mentioned
x-men obviously there was a lot more to
it but it's undeniable that Ralph had
felt a kinship with this applicant at
that moment and and it couldn't hurt
these people are human I mean like all
of us they really tended to follow on
there's one individual who thought his
life as a writer would be largely over
if he did not get into an Ivy I think
it's not giving it away too much from
the book to say that that does not
happen and you as an applicant to get to
watch as he tried to pick up the pieces
I certainly identified with him as
someone who thought as an applicant that
deny he was so important at that time in
my life yes shun of students and parents
to your book and I really have a
three-part question in your
presentations did you see more students
or parents there how would you
characterize the the reaction to the
book in in a sort of general more
emotional or analytical tone and what
did they pick out about the book and did
it surprise you at all I mean first
question was whether I saw more parents
and students I saw far more parents and
students partly I think it was because
students are so busy and many many
parents would tell me that their child
had wanted to come but was you know
doing a homework assignment I mean a lot
of these events were on weeknights and
that's a hard night to get away I also
think the fact that it's a hardcover
book I don't remember opening many
hardcover books as a high school student
and I
and and I think that but I think that it
is and I think that many of the readers
of the book are our parents although
some students are reading it I think
it's not the worst thing in the world
for parents to read I think that the
book intentionally I'm although it tells
a story it tells this as a narrative
really tries to anticipate a lot of the
questions that a college counselor or an
admissions officer might get from a
parent with the hope that maybe some of
those questions can be answered before
they get to a college counselor or an
admissions officer so it's not the worst
thing in the world that parents are
reading this and maybe I hope taking to
heart the message that they should not
be on their children's backs to that
there was a particular way to do certain
things your last question was to did
they pick out and did that surprise you
at all given what you thought you were
writing about I I think that they it's
again it's hard to generalize everybody
read their own story into the book and
and and they would ask very particular
questions about their child had a 1200 s
80 in these activities and did I think
you know they could get in and it did
but certainly some parents have have
said that it was hard to read the book
while going through the process because
it was so immediate to them but
certainly there's a reaction we know
intellectually that affirmative action
is practiced at a place like Westland we
know that there has to be some
accommodation made for kids of color and
and and and and some attempt to sort of
level the playing field for them but
even though we know intellectually I
think seeing it actually played out in
the book has been upsetting to some
people particularly parents who are
white but it's hard to sort of
generalize I think more than anything
one of the reactions so did surprise me
is that there's a real skepticism that
the process is as human as I described
it and I've gotten a number of skeptical
questions about didn't Wesley and sort
of put on a show for you while you were
there and I try to tell them that I was
there so long that that would have been
impossible and but they still they've
convinced themselves that the files get
thrown down the stairs
the far the one that travels the
farthest wins they've convinced
themselves that that an admissions
officer open the file look right at the
s80 score and if that scores and high
enough this folder gets closed and put
to the side and there's almost only so
much convincing you can do in a
situation like that but some parents
happily many parents really have said
they felt reassured by sort of seeing
this yes picked up on what is I had a
stepdaughter who about six years ago was
on the wait list at Brown and they had
said to her that if she would agree to
go they'd make her first on the waitlist
and she asked me if she could do that if
she could change her mind and and I said
no at the time and then had some some
bling regrets out and she didn't she
said she didn't agree to that and then I
had some lingering regrets about that
because she might have gotten on in and
and gone but she wasn't willing to to
make that commitment at the time but I
suffered through that sort of honesty
deliver their second is that but my my
son's in college right now and he
demonstrated that fessing up to your rug
drug gets in it in high school does not
get you into necessarily overcome other
problems that you have on your resume is
because into very many places then it
really I couldn't in terms of the the
question about drugs and and and Becca
is the hardly the only applicant to a
college like Westland or any other
college who has even a fleeting
experience with drugs and even chooses
to mention it an application I couldn't
possibly generalize over whether it's a
good idea to talk about it or not some
students have no choice the suspension
is listed on the file and they have to
explain it in becca's case she really
didn't have to say anything it was one
of these suspensions that was sort of
off the books I like anything else this
process is messy and and so much of it
in a case like that might hinge on who
picks up the file and and and and what
else is in the file Becca's case is
complicated by the fact that her s80
score has not hit 1,300 her father's a
lawyer in century city california the
expectation is that becca could have
done better particularly given the the
courses that she had taken in high
school so they were it was there were
complications
and you can't really generalize I don't
think one thing that I have learned
though is that as a parent you really
can call up an admissions officer a
guidance counselor certainly can and ask
this very question hypothetically how
should I handle this how would it be
received you can get some guidance and
there are some institutional
personalities and some institutions
where Becca was advised by her college
counselor not to bother applying because
the college counselor was savvy enough
to know at these institutions that she
would not get a fair hearing wessling
was not one of those institutions she
was encouraged by her college counselor
to apply here yes what would you say was
your personal say favorite most unique
kid not not you know the exact kid but
you know what were the characteristics
of say the kid that say stays in your
mind is the one that you liked the best
or the most unique like where the heck
did this kid ever come from I really and
I'm sure you'll consider it a cop out of
an answer I mean it's I mean there were
six applicants we followed Carter was
sort of an aside and I loved Carter's
story and I loved after hearing that
story from Charlotte and Judy actually
calling Carter at the Letterman Show and
meeting him and telling him he had had
this wonderful impact here they each of
them was unique and certainly all the
applicants that i mentioned i had great
admiration for and and and certainly
they were out specs of each of them that
i could relate to and others like you
know Giuliana's background and and
Becca's experience with the brownie
frankly that I could not react relate to
one of the other applicants of the book
I felt incredibly far from on one sense
he his name is [ __ ] Z while i was at
Wesleyan Ralph decided that Wesleyan for
the first time in a long time should try
to recruit a Native American in the name
of diversity Ralph felt that you had to
start somewhere and that as Stanford and
Dartmouth and Cornell had done that
Wesleyan needed to make Native Americans
priority in search of this elusive
person Ralph rented retro flew to
Albuquerque rented an SUV drove halfway
up the side of a Mesa in the snow to
find this incredible school for Native
American kids that graduate
15 kids a year it was there that he met
magazine and I would have thought on the
surface that I had nothing in common
with magazine given his background
growing up but jib la in northern
Minnesota I'm not sure Ralph having
grown up in California the child of
Mexican immigrants would have felt that
he had much in common with magazine and
yet both the Ralph and I felt drawn to
MIG aziz encyclopedic knowledge of film
which is knowledge that ultimately drew
make azita Westland and so it was it was
fun for me to see a bit of myself in
each of these applicants and I certainly
couldn't pick a favorite thank you very
much